well we were actually just on set of
prison break and we were chatting with
you and Dominic how's he doing by the
way
I know you had a little mishap on set
he's a tank
have we had any other stunt mishaps or
any other injuries tomorrow okay good
good how have the stunts been for you
the second time around different at 44
I'm 34 I do what I can
but if I need my character to look cool
and like he knows what he's doing and my
stunt double can execute that better
then I'm happy to step aside it's just
in service of telling the best story
about the coolest thing possible for
that guy congratulations are in order
you just got a really cool overall deal
with the CW where your character can
kind of pop up in any Oh Greg Berlanti
show yeah it's a sweet deal it's the
most fun I've had as far as a character
I have a lot of respect and love for
Michael Scofield the Captain Cold is a
good time and so the opportunity to kind
of pop up and do a little song and dance
on the flash or legends and then get out
and not have to do like the kind of
expositional heavy lifting a Michael
Scofield
has to do it's good time
you